Peter, every cloud user keeps sharing these insane results.
Mine still needs emotional support just to rename a file.
That's because you're using plain cloud.
These five skills completely change how it works.
Five out of how many.
Over a hundred thousand.
But honestly, you only need these.
Alright, what's the first one?
Find skills.
Just tell Claude what you're building and it'll search its entire skill library.
Find the right tools and install them automatically.
Uh, yes.
Finally, software that reads the manual so I don't have to.
What's next?
Superpowers.
It forces Claude to slow down, plan the task properly,
and double-check its work before making changes.
So, if you were AI mistakes?
Exactly.
Then there's Claude Man, which gives Claude memory a cross session,
so you never have to explain your project all over again.
Incredible.
We finally taught AI to remember yesterday.
Then impeccable for front end gives Claude real design taste using premium UI references.
And lastly, task observer quietly learns how you work and continuously improves your skills in the background.
That's actually insane.
Beautiful.
We didn't just upgrade the AI.
We gave it a personality.
If you want to try these yourself, just join my broadcast channel.
You'll find everything there.
Follow for more.